we start with a breaking news and
Manchester City have won the Champions
League to secure the treble they beat
Inter Milan one nil in Istanbul or Sky's
Rob Harris is in Istanbul forest and Rob
they've only gone and done it
they have they've completed a treble
only achieved once before by an english
team they're great Rivals Manchester
United and Manchester City here in
Istanbul by beating Inter Milan one nil
have completed the set of major trophies
in the 15 years of Abu Dhabi ownership
and ownership that's transformed the
club with billions of wealth and it's
delivered this sporting greatness that
has the fans erupting and celebration in
the attitude Stadium this wasn't City on
the pitch at their all-conquering best
but they have conquered Europe for the
first time